you're well position seems to me to make
this into something wonderful I think
it's a very exciting development to see
to that stock and finally get the place
for for the arts and the sciences that
his now should be the hallmark of stock
on my mind and I also think that the
important to have a science of a public
forum that there is some we can invite
really outstanding scientist in both in
science in humanities in politics to
address questions and have have all of
importance like energy global warming
but you have a big job ahead of you to
really get it organized in a way so that
it's a friendly not pompous but so the
people feel a kiss we like to come here
because it's and it's a deal location
with the people walking water-miscible
along tonight hey asia museum hill